one of my favorite franchises of all
time i think i've seen it more than
anything else is all the screen movies i
love that
yeah and so this this opening scene was
so awesome
because it feels like a direct omash's
scream but then she instantly identifies
the killer
you're like yes tell me about that
hello yes i'm so happy that you said it
so obviously it's very clearly stealing
all of the amazing parts of the drew
barrymore opening of the original scream
and that was definitely a choice um down
to kind of the slo-mo run that she has
when she when skull mask catches up to
her in the mall but i'm just so happy
that you said it because that was the
thing we
were like we're going to introduce this
we're going to orient you into this
world of the 90s
the 90s slasher that you've seen but
we're going to unmask him we're going to
show him in that and kind of let you
know that this is different
and we're in a whole different world so
i'm so glad that you noticed and also i
agree i mean the scream franchise is
incredible amazing marco beltrami who
did the music for that is my composer on
these movies
which i was so lucky to have hello
still alive who is this it's happening
again i loved this
trilogy it was so much fun i love
slashers i love like screaming friday
the 13th all of this but
it felt so fresh and unique especially
with the release order and everything
they're doing with that so
what is it about the fear street trilogy
that excited you the most olivia we'll
start with you
i think that exactly i'm a huge huge
huge horror fan so when i
got these i was like oh i never thought
i would get to be in a movie like the
ones that i watched growing up
and so on the surface i was like this is
incredible like they're such
like kick-ass horror movies and then
like going through the scripts and
reading them and doing the auditions
it was they're just so layered and they
like subvert so much and they give a
voice to so many different people
and it just felt like a true honor to be
a part of something that like
really felt like an important piece of
art and an important movie and trilogy
and then also
just to be so nostalgic and like get to
live in this like fantasy world that i
had always
watched on tv or like on tv and in the
movies and um
yeah it was truly like a dream project
it's always my dream as an actor to tell
stories that
are important that are groundbreaking
they're constructive to our society and
i feel like fear street definitely
is that deals with so many themes
including you know systemic oppression
the central characters are minorities
you know
we don't often see this in stories and
especially not in the horror genre so i
really really loved playing my
characters because i was contributing to
a story that did all of that
as well as you know jumping back in time
it's not often that we get opportunities
to play more than one character in the
same world so that was also
such a dream dream role for sure i love
that we were gonna be uh
speaking up for the outsiders basically
in this movie but uh when i first
heard about the movie i was like wait
they're dropping three of them like
back to back to back like oh i gotta
like get this like
i've never heard of that been done
before so i was like that's what really
like
intrigued me when i first heard about it
i was like wow that sounds dope
these massacres happen in shadyside over
and over
just the idea that they're all that
we're doing these three films
all together it was so exciting to be a
part of something that
felt so fresh uh something that i didn't
even know
had been done before where you somebody
you're filming three movies at once
um it was so exciting in that in that
regard and and
lee our director who's just such a
genius to be able to pull it off
um and to be the thing that you get to
see now is like
i was instantly drawn to that being like
wow this is like it feels like we're
doing something
groundbreaking i had read a lot of fear
street books as a kid
so i was already just excited when i
knew that they were making movies of
them
and then my excitement only grew when i
read these scripts
met lee met this cast and yeah
exactly everything daryl said and then
also just the way that netflix is
releasing them
that people get to watch the films so
close together i feel like is
such a cool thing to do with this uh
trilogy
i really love that they were so clearly
uh fun and exciting and
fit the genre so well but also
sort of a trojan horse for some really
interesting ideas
i think that was the most exciting thing
for me
and it's it's fun when when we're going
to work and covering ourselves in blood
um for five months it's nice to to
to think about why we're doing this and
that was really clear
when i heard that rl steins fury street
was getting adapted my
thought was like oh we're gonna have
like a nice little creepy like pg
goosebumpsy
type thing yeah no it goes all the way
with the gore
and everything i love it what made you
want to go just like all the way with
this franchise for me
i knew that these were slasher movies at
their heart and i feel like slasher
movies need to be r-rated you need to
have a
lot of blood you need to have a lot of
dead teenagers
there was no world where they couldn't
be rated i think also as a kind of a fan
of the books
thinking back on reading them when i was
a teenager they felt subversive they
felt edgy
and i wanted that like spirit of that
and to really push the envelope and kind
of
you know encourage people to maybe
sneakily watch it even if they're a
little younger than they should be
[Music]
come back from that [ __ ]
[Music]
you